[Music]
speaking of food that you could boot up
yeah actually let's get that mustard
watermelon in here or whatever that was
a great segue
it's a great segue all right oh thank
you
wow that looks disgusting by the way
speaking hold on before we do this real
quick
we watched the uh the jackass movie the
original one
yeah because there's a new one coming
out yeah dude it is so [ __ ] funny but
the moments i laughed the hardest and
when people
vomited this is what this guy does
this guy this guy does um
oh this is what it was he it was the
prank where he tried to go to a toilet
store and take a [ __ ] in the middle of
toilet but
the first time he did it he had to [ __ ]
so bad he's [ __ ] in the car on the way
there
and all the camera dudes like flip the
cameras around on themselves and are
puking because it smelled so bad
and then there's another one this dude
pisses on a snow cone
he takes he takes a bunch of snow from
the ground and pisses on and then eats
it
and then throws up and it's just him and
it's like the funniest [ __ ] thing
ever you're laughing like children dude
it was so funny
all right what do we got here explain
these all right so that on the
left looks like mustard watermelon
mustard on watermelon
yeah kyle can you tell us what these are
yeah so we got watermelon and mustard
carrots with sriracha
and chili and then banana with
mayo oh
[ __ ] that you want that you're so evil
you are what that's evil
only one of them no way that doesn't
i love those two things separately and i
like usually i can stomach you like this
like the mustard watermelon
is totally fine for me i'm pretty sure
but mayo on a banana you
sick [ __ ] if that's the lie you're an
evil person that is sadistic dude that
is sick
sick in the [ __ ] head for that so one
of these is not a
food trend it's just one you invented
correct
which one do you think it is why don't
you eat the one you think is fake
no you could eat the one that's good and
then
you know i'm gonna first here let's try
it first and then i'll watch you bro
you have to try one of these look at
that's a tiny little bit of moisture
i literally don't have
save that for the only fans man
yeah it's coming back out no that's not
bad okay that's actually not bad
that one's oh that's pretty bad actually
yeah
yeah that aftertaste is not great yeah i
think that one
is real though i think that one's
actually on tick tock okay
yeah bananamate sriracha and carrot
banana mayo next
what the [ __ ] is on why is it all what
did you put on this sriracha carrots and
chili
chili
seems like it'd be all right i'm sorry
why i just told that whole story and
it helps now it's my turn yeah that
one's that one's fine
this is this just looks disgusting july
20 22. you're training for the big fight
i'm not eating this oh i can't eat this
look at that get it get a [ __ ] zoom
in oh
it's possessed man it tried to fly into
your hand
oh no this is sick dude this is
sick now i hold this banana up
would he have ever done this to your
face
[Laughter]
did his penis ever ever look like this
after you're done with them
i'm not eating this i think this one's
fake kyle and you're you're sick
[ __ ] that one's real
the carrot one's fake the carrot one was
good
that was the fake one dude the banana
one
who eats that someone actually eats down
on tick tock banana with mayo
[ __ ] dude that's horrible yeah let's see
let's see that clip because
that is disgusting i got it we're
pulling it up
give us a sec we didn't have a prep
the cara one's pretty good
good because i wasn't carrot that was
cow knuckle
it was actually fermented cow foot
i just would be so funny if you put like
if it's not actually sriracha was like
the bomb sauce or something like that
i was just [ __ ] dying for the rest of
the episode
a very ripe banana if it has brown spots
like this that's what you want as for
the mayo you can use anything
any mayo you like and from then on it's
pretty straightforward you just peel the
banana add a nice dollop of mayo and
then you eat it
it's so sweet it's so creamy it's like
you're eating a really
savory rich banana crust what did i say
trust me on this
trust me on this
he does not hold back on those bites
he eats a banana like a cartoon
character dude
two bites that [ __ ] is gone
that's like that's like two and a half
servings of mayo dude
that's unreal first of all [ __ ] you if
you're putting a dollop of anything on
anything a dollop
that's that is disgusting man that this
is a dollar
that is a dollar yeah just that tininess
not that
yeah that that [ __ ] he gave that thing a
haircut man
see and kyle just full-on dipped it in
the mail bro restart it look at the wide
angle that he
which is even gross do you think about
putting a banana inside
mayo like that
yo refresh that why did he use a
wide-angle lens
trust me on this it is so good the most
important thing is to have a very ripe
banana if it has brown spots like this
that's what you want as for the mayo you
can use anything any mayo you like
and from then on it's pretty
straightforward you just peel the banana
add a nice dollop of mayo
and then you eat it bruh that's so much
mayo it's an
ice cream scoop of mayo i love mayo but
that's so
much mayo oh man come on man
that thumbnail
[Laughter]
why'd you pick that frame you know why
he picked that frame
first trap that's the third strike
thirst trap it is bro
it's crazy people that do food stuff
like this
is this the hub people
people that do food stuff like this do
like
they do crazy thirst traps like that
like there's like when i was
i did this video about the all the dudes
that he eat like the spiciest foods on
tick tock
yeah and all of them eat these gigantic
pickles that are like
that are dipped in tapatio like they
open the packages and they're like one
of
those
giant [ __ ] pickles and it's just
soaking wet
and these dudes like hang it and go oh
it looks so
i'll spicy it like it's
wild bro and all the comments like you
know
what you were doing that bottom left one
he's sucking off the green goblin's
finger with that man that is crazy
instruction's unclear i consumed it
through the wrong hole
[Laughter]
this man smokes cigarettes backwards
jesus christ oh [ __ ]
dog you all right [ __ ]
how about it [ __ ] i'm about to have some
vomiting going on
my penis i'm having some i'm having some
busting going on
my penis is vomiting the royal family
says